a lot of emotions running together for
Pamela goins-brown Overjoyed grateful
blessed nervous excited all those
emotions running together right now we
sat down with her at North Las Vegas
city hall where she served as
councilwoman for the past 11 years in
Ward 2. North Las Vegas has been her
home since the 1960s and as North Las
Vegas mayor she would continue to pave
the way in a number of firsts and I
think in the state of Nevada as well
absolutely first African-American female
mayor the first African-American for
Ward 2 and then just following the
legacy of my parents and my father
because he served as mayor Pro tem in
councilman councilman in Ward 2 in his
time she is ecstatic to have the
opportunity to keep that Legacy going I
am just so proud to be their daughter
and it just I couldn't have started
without you know their guidance and
raising me to be the woman that I am
today representing a city with so much
diversity and momentum with Apex
Industrial Park the city's job creation
Zone project downtown revitalizations
expansion of the veteran Center as well
to name a few we're attracting Fortune
500 companies to come set up shop here
in little North Las Vegas so and that's
just going to be good for the entire
Valley with job creation stable
stabilization of jobs and higher paying
jobs I am just so excited um this next
Journey
um and I just want to make sure that I
do it well and that I continue to listen
to my constituents because their voices
really matter to me